there's a story floating around about
Elizabeth Warren that has her taking a
lot of heat from people on the left
because she made 1.9 million dollars
over 30 years doing legal consulting
work for a number of different
corporations now let me I don't even
know IIIi don't even know why I do this
I know I'm gonna get crushed but I'll do
the normal disclaimers I'm not endorsing
Elizabeth Warren I'm not defending
Elizabeth Warren's particular work in
any of the cases we're going to discuss
but what I am here to tell you is I
think that some of the critiques around
this are a little bit misplaced some
people are saying that this warren thing
is a story of misogyny that elizabeth
warren is being slammed for making 1.9
million dollars over 30 years whereas
you have people like michael bloomberg
spending 30 million on his own campaign
and nobody questions that nobody
questions Bezos is income whatever that
does there's a identity politics thing
that's being said about this there are
others who are saying this is really
about corporate cronyism centrist status
quo politics and Elizabeth Warren not as
a progressive but rather as a tool of
the centrist corporate establishment so
once again disclosure this is not an
endorsement of Elizabeth Warren this is
a warning that we should pick our
battles and pick battles that make sense
particularly within the framework of the
Democratic primary so let's go through
the facts the report is that Elizabeth
Warren put out a detailed compensation
list partially because of pressure from
the Peabody Judge campaign and it was
revealed that she worked for about 30
years as a legal consultant there were
cases that she worked on as a consultant
while she was teaching law mostly at
Harvard and at the University of
Pennsylvania now Elizabeth Warren is an
expert in bankruptcy a lot of the cases
related to bankruptcy makes sense and in
total it was 1.9 million dollars in
income over 30 years so number one this
is about sixty three thousand dollars a
year now there's no question that
Elizabeth Warren is hugely privileged we
knew that back when she ran for Senate
and I interviewed her in person I said
you know you have rhetoric that is one
thing and at the same time you are very
wealthy or
self she's her net worth is known to be
around ten to twelve million dollars now
I think it was more in the single digits
then I think she's made a lot of money
from from books and maybe speaking since
I'm not totally sure but we've known
that Elizabeth Warren has a lot of money
for a very long time what I hate to
break to people is that earning sixty
three thousand dollars in extra income
per year doing legal consulting when you
are a relatively well-known and
respected law professor is not shocking
it is not a crazy amount of money when
we're talking about Bloomberg and Trump
and Bezos and and you know Sheldon
Adelson and all of this stuff Elizabeth
Warren over thirty years making 63 grand
a year doing legal work which is what
lawyers do it's really not a scandal now
you can say some of the specific people
she represented are problematic okay now
you've got a little bit better of an
argument she represented a company
called LTV steel or consulted for them
who didn't want to pay into a fund for
coal miners she was on the wrong side of
that the progressive thing to do is you
support the miners she was hired by LTV
steel and she represented them can we go
after her for that sure in the same way
that you can go after a defense attorney
for representing someone that you think
is guilty that's fair game that's just a
question of what do we think about
lawyers she advised Dow Chemical about
some breast implant litigation and made
20 grand for that it was now chemical on
the side of people who had been hurt by
their breast implants no she wasn't and
we can criticize her for that she
advised one of Enron's creditors
remember Enron imploded and lots of
people lost money she advised one of
Enron's creditors most of the cases were
pretty mundane and they never made
headlines now let's discuss the talking
points that are floating around there
are memes floating around about Wow a
woman earns two million over 30 years oh
my goodness meanwhile Mike Bloomberg
spends 35 million in two weeks on his
campaign and no one bats an eye
first of all people are talking about
how much money Bloomberg is spending so
I don't think that it's fair to say
there's not reporting about that but I
don't think it's about male female in
particular here I think it's about
expectations Bloomberg is held to a
different standard he is a billionaire
buying his way into this race Elizabeth
is rightly seen as someone closer to
Bernie but with a more corporate past
there's no question so I think this is
the wrong area of focus I don't think
that this reveals anything new about
Elizabeth Warren I am very concerned and
have been about her association with
someone named Suzy Orman who is a sort
of financial pop finance person who
gives some kind of weird advice that's
not new but this entire 1.9 million
earnings over 30 years was pushed by the
Buddha judge people and ultimately I
don't think we've really learned much
from it on Bron policy Bernie remains
the most progressive Elizabeth Warren is
a close second we know Bernie got to
where he is politically from a hippie
activist past in Brooklyn and Vermont
Elizabeth Warren on the other hand has
been pulled left politically coming from
a more centrist status quo legal
political corporate world and we deal
with their policy proposals as they are
today period and I don't think this is
the right story for the left to go crazy
over if I'm wrong let me know and no I
have not endorsed Elizabeth Warren in
this segment